a la altura de un triángulo es cuatro
centímetros más grande que el doble de
su base el área del triángulo es de 168
centímetros cuadrados cuál es la base
del triángulo lo primero que vamos a
hacer es dibujar ese triángulo que nos
dicen vamos a dibujar nuestro triángulo
muy sencillo este es el triángulo
esto de aquí es la altura
y esto de aquí abajo va a ser la base
nos dicen que la base que llamamos be
y la altura que vamos a llamar h
va a ser cuatro centímetros más grande
que el doble de la base entonces cuatro
más dos por ver cuál es el haga de el
triángulo pues es base por altura entre
dos o un medio por base por altura el
área de un triángulo es igual a un medio
por la base por la altura y vamos a
sustituir la altura por esto de acá esto
va a ser igual a un medio por la base
por la altura que la altura es cuatro
más dos por b está ahora todo en
términos de la base vamos a simplificar
un poco más esto vamos a distribuir un
medio por b por todo lo que se encuentra
dentro de este paréntesis así que esto
va a ser igual a un medio b por 44 entre
12 22 b y un medio de b por 2 b este 2
entre 2 que se cancela b por bs cuadrada
nos queda más b al cuadrado y en el
problema nos dicen que el área es igual
a 168 así que esto 168 que es el área va
a ser igual a 2 b más b cuadrada
vamos a restar 168 en ambos lados de la
ecuación y nos va a quedar 168 menos 2 b
más b cuadrada va a ser igual hacer ya
que 168 menos 168 es igual a 0 168 es un
número extraño como para encontrar dos
números que multiplicados en 168 aunque
me parece que el 12 x el 14 nos da esta
cantidad
podemos usar una ecuación cuadrática
para resolverlo pero creo que el 12 por
el 14 funciona aunque uno de ellos
deberá ser negativo porque tenemos que
es un menos que esto no lo puse quien
menos 168 acuérdense que lo arrestamos
de este lado menos 168 es 14 y 12 tienen
dos unidades de diferencia por lo que
creo que si nos va a dar este menos 2
que estén bien
vamos a escribirlo esto va a ser igual a
b más 14
por lo menos 12
y esto debe ser igual a 0 para que esto
pueda ser 0 uno de estos dos o ambos de
estos elementos deben de ser cero para
que esto sea cero b debe ser igual a
menos 14 y para que esto sea 0 b deberá
ser igual a 12
y como estamos hablando de distancias
realmente no nos va a interesar aquí una
distancia negativa no tendría sentido
así que el valor de b que nos interesa
es de 12 la base mide 12 la base es
igual a 12 que es nuestra opción se
pasemos al siguiente problema
x cuadrada menos 4 x 4 cuadrada entre 3
x menos 6 y cuadrada reducido a su
mínima expresión lo que nos piden es
factorizar y cancelar algunas cosas para
dejar esta ecuación en su mínima
expresión
comencemos trabajando con el numerador
esto de arriba luce como un cuadrado
perfecto porque si tenemos menos 2 al
cuadrado será 4 y cuadrada y menos dos
menos 2 es igual a menos 4 y así que la
expresión de arriba queda como queda
como x menos 2 x
x2
y lo escriba así de esta manera porque
algo me dice que uno de estos términos
se va a cancelar más adelante eso sale
del siguiente razonamiento imaginen voy
a escribirlo aquí a un lado en otro
color para que se note que es algo
aparte imaginen que tenemos esto en x
cuadrada x cuadrada menos 4 x + 4 esto
lo podríamos factorizar como x menos 2
por x menos 2 esto es un 4 no se nota
que sea un 4 pero es un 4 ahí está
pero nuestra ocasión de aquí tenemos de
acá y se cuadrada aquí
así que podemos visualizar esto como lo
escribimos aquí abajo x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos 4 x x x + 4 x y cuadrada
que también se puede ver como x cuadrada
menos 2 x 2 x +
27 todo esto elevado al cuadrado
pero espero que puedan notar que este
numerador este numerador es lo mismo que
acabo de escribir aquí y es a partir de
aquí que tuve la intuición de factorizar
de esta manera el numerador pues qué
números a sumar se nos dan dos por dos
pues obviamente 12 x xi y que el número
al elevarse al cuadrado nos da 4
cuadrada pues también 2 es por eso que
tenemos esta factorización bueno todo
esto que acabamos de hacer fue sólo para
simplificar el numerador ahora vamos a
trabajar con el denominador que a la
vista salta que ambos términos son
divisibles entre 3 porque aquí hay un 3
aquí hay una y el 6 es divisible entre 3
también tenemos una ya cuadrada que
podemos dividir entre ella así que vamos
a poner el numerador vamos a sacar el 3
y tres equis y entre 13 va a ser igual a
equis
-6 y al cuadrado entre 3 lleva a ser
igual a 2 porsche
qué es una muy buena señal el tener un
término aquí que podemos cancelar con un
término del numerador y así lo hacemos
estos se cancelan y nos va a quedar esto
como x menos dos entre tres y esta es la
ecuación reducida a su mínima expresión
muy bien pasamos con el siguiente
problema que es el 65 que es un problema
muy similar nos dice simplifique esta
ecuación 6x al cuadrado más 21 x más 9
entre 4 x al cuadrado menos 1 a su
mínima expresión
hicimos el numerador y luce como si
todos los términos fueron múltiplos de 3
es decir todos estos elementos son
divisibles entre 3 vamos a escribirlo 3
por 6 x cuadrada entre 3 va a ser igual
a 2 x cuadrada +
21 entre 3 7 7 x + 9 3 3 3 por 3 19 y
veamos el denominador este tiene la
forma parecida am
a cuadrada menos b cuadrado aquí sería 2
x a al cuadrado sería 4 x cuadrada y
aquí me iguala 1-1 al cuadrado es 1 así
que podemos escribir esto como a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada esto es igual
a más ve por a menos b - b vamos a
escribirlo aquí abajo sustituyendo los
valores de a esto es igual a el
denominador a queramos que era 2x
ve quedamos que es uno
a igual 2 x menos b que es menos 1 vamos
a ver si podemos seguir factor izando y
simplificando el numerador para ver si
hay algo que podemos cancelar con lo que
tenemos en el denominador analicemos lo
que se encuentra aquí dentro del
paréntesis voy a ponerlo en otro color
voy a escribir la parte esto
vamos a analizarlo acá lo re escribo 2x
cuadrada más 7 x más 3
bueno aquí tenemos que va a ser 2x
multiplicado más algo que todavía no sé
que se llamó b y esto va a estar
multiplicado también por x +
x más otro algo que tampoco conozco en
este momento pues 2x por x es 2 x al
cuadrado estos 2 me dan esto
él ve más a deberá ser igual a 3 no sé
quizá uno de ellos sea tres y el otro
sea uno pero sólo soy tratando de
imaginar qué par de números eran vamos a
multiplicar esto 2x
vas ve por x esto va a ser igual a 2 x
al cuadrado 2 x x x 2 x al cuadrado b x
x + x x
2 x x + 2 x x
más ve por
por a vamos a agrupar los términos
comunes
vamos a ver nada más tengo uno con x al
cuadrado va a ser dos x cuadrada
los términos con x son estos va a ser
igual
por equis estoy nuevas factor izando los
elementos constantes de estos dos
términos
por a
y esto tiene que ser igual a esta parte
de acá así que esto lo escribirá abajo
bueno esto de quién tiene que ser igual
al 2 x al cuadrado este no hay problema
directamente se ve que es igual
esto de aquí esto de aquí todo esto
tiene que ser igual a 7 x
7x y todo esto de aquí ahora debe ser
igual a 3
3 porque son esos elementos de aquí
bueno
de esto vemos que dos más dos a deberá
ser igual a siete y también de este otro
lado vemos que ahora deberá ser igual a
tres b por an debe ser igual a tres qué
números multiplicados me dan 3 y 1 x 2 y
sumado por el otro me da 7
bueno vamos a ver si yo aquí sustituyó
por ejemplo el a por un 33 por 12 6 y el
b tendría que ser 13 por 26 más 17 esto
se cumple y si fuera esto 1 por 3 va a
ser igual a 3 así que esa combinación de
igual a 3 y b igual a 1 me funciona
entonces lo sustituimos aquí va a ser
igual a 2x queremos que b es uno más uno
por x más a x más 3
entonces nuestra expresión del numerador
la vamos a reescribir aquí abajo
recordamos que era 3 por todo esto
3 x 2 x + 1 x x 3 x 3
ese es el numerador y el denominador
pues ya lo habíamos simplificado que
daba 2 x + 1 x 2 x 1 y que creen tenemos
un término que podemos cancelar aquí
arriba y aquí abajo quedándonos nuestra
expresión simplificada como 3 x x + 3
entre 2 x menos 1 y con esto encontramos
la solución que nos pide aquí está la
simplificación
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo